[Music]
Kylie Jenner is setting the record
straight on plastic surgery rumors it's
just so crazy how people make this up in
their minds the 21 year old makeup mogul
is paper magazine's February covergirl
rocking a variety of blonde hairdos and
funky outfits inside the mag kylie opens
up about growing up in the spotlight and
her ever-changing look kylie insists
she's never had work done on her face
quote people think I fully went under
the knife and completely reconstructed
my face which is completely false I'm
terrified
I would never they don't understand what
good hair and makeup and like fillers
can really do yep Kylie always keeps it
real she added its fillers I'm not
denying that if my true fans are want to
know personals like them Kylie also
opened up about her growing empire as a
makeup mogul what would you say your job
title is business
mínimo go mini christina in july forbes
valued Kylie cosmetics at nearly a
billion dollars making her one of the
youngest self-made billionaires kylie
caught some flak for that coming from
the Kardashian family and all but she
tells paper she was actually financially
cut off when she was 15 and spent her
own dollars to create her company wote
my parents told me I needed to make my
own money I did have a platform but none
of my money is inherited she made her
own money for over a decade she put it
in the bank
she saved every nipple and then when she
decided she really you know decided on
what she wanted to do she spent her
money on a venture that could have gone
south or north and it did really well
everyone has a team I don't care who you
are how you you know but when you don't
get it from someone else that's helped
me so it's not like that was handed to
her 20:18 was a big year for Kylie for
many reasons including becoming a mom
she and boyfriend rapper Travis Scott
welcomed their daughter stormy in
February quote it's genuinely what I
wanted to be a young mom I thought this
is what I want to do and if people
accepted or don't accept it then I'm
okay with every outcome
[Music]
you